uh
thirty years ago uh martian solved the
problem for
uh finding maximum value revenue auction
with one items with independent
distributions
and after that for many years that
people have
been interested in the case when one
wants to sell
multi items and it's a a
difficult problem and i still a lot of
research
going on and uh in this talk we are
going to address two questions
uh the first one is there a simple
mechanism that can achieve constant
approximation
of optimal revenue and the second
question
uh can division incentive compatibility
revenue be much higher than the
dominant strategy incentive
compatibility
and we'll give some solutions to
these questions under the assumption of
independence of the different input
distributions
but otherwise they can be arbitrary
and we made progress
by uh introducing a particular way
of reducing a multi-item auction
into end disjoint one buyer
k-item auctions and the
results in this paper were presented
earlier in the year at the soda
conference
and let's start with some background in
the simplest case
you have n equal to 1 and k equal to 1
and the the seller has partial knowledge
of the buyer's interest
and captured by a a distribution f
and how does the seller maximize the
revenue and
and now there is a
a a natural solution is
just try to maximize the
x the price
which maximize the x times the
probability of
the the price being accepted
and now
how about the multiple items and the
multiple buyers
and now for k equal to
one item and m buyers as we mentioned
the meyerson solves the problem
uh completely and uh when k
is greater than one it's more complex
even for one buyer
so uh let's look at the one one buyer
case
under the assumption that the
distribution of the items
are independent
and uh so let's use this notation to
denote the revenue that can be obtained
by two simple algorithms one is to
sell separately and the other is to
use bundling and in the seminal paper by
heart and the nissan in 2012
they uh they asked some
really interesting questions about the
structures
of the multi-item
auctions for example whether the uh
revenue is uh it's
it's it's sub-additive uh namely that
that that if you if you have two
options it's not possible to obtain much
much more
revenue by combining them into into one
and now they
apply the structural results obtained
to study really concrete questions
for example the uh if you use simple
mechanisms how far can it be away
from the optimal revenue and they they
proved that
selling separately will achieve uh by
off at most by a factor of log k square
and uh the bundling uh is can be off
by at most a log factor
if all the uh distributions are
identical
and uh later uh it was shown
that these bounds can be improved so the
settings separately can be
taken one log factor off and now for the
iid case
then dependently actually achieve the
optimal revenue
and and these bonds are uh tight
and now uh what about the uh
so but this doesn't give
a algorithm that um obtain a constant
factor
for the general case and so finally
uh bubba f at all uh approved a very
elegant result
showing that if you uh look at the
selling separately
and the bundling then it's off by
at most a constant factor
and so now the question is that what
about
the case when you have n buyers
is it possible to have a simple
algorithm to
achieve a constant factor of the optimal
and
that was exactly the question one that
we were
uh we raised and
so to answer the that first question
will will prove a theorem one
that shows that there's a simple and
truthful mechanism that
achieves a constant fraction of revenue
and the approach is to reduce the
problem
to end disjoint one buyer
problem and using that
insight to obtain a constant
approximation for this problem
and now uh this reduction
actually is useful not just for
answering question one but
for answering question as well it shows
that the bayesian
can be at most a constant factor of more
revenue than the dominant strategy
i see and there are some other
consequences as well and let's start
with looking at this program
in solving theorem one so we are
uh we'll kind of combine
the reduction and uh the other steps
together
to uh show you uh in one
package on how this simple algorithm
would look like but the reduction will
be
become pretty clear and they'll be
useful for other purposes
and before showing you the concrete
reduction and and
implementation will uh
uh make a remark about the uh
the motivation for this one this end
to one buyer reduction and
now in general
uh for any mechanism if you put the
constraint
that every item has to be assigned to
some buyer and uh you furthermore
uh you can assign them only to the
highest bidder
if you put this very strong constraint
then uh
it's clear that the mechanism must sell
each item separately
using the second press uh victory uh
victory
auction so so you cannot do anything
better but how about more how about
relax
relaxing those constraints a little bit
let's say that
any item if assigned can only go to the
highest bidder so
the question is can such mechanism
any of such mechanism if you take the
best of them
can you achieve our purpose namely to
achieve a fraction of the optimal
revenue
so uh the thinking is that instead of
just blindly trying to find
a a a good simple algorithm
let's say that let's
search within a limited domain of
particular type
of mechanisms and see if it's possible
to already get a good solution from this
class and and the reason why
constraining the class is a good idea
is that uh as in our case
uh it turns out that when you make this
constraint uh it's very easy to
characterize
the kind of of of uh
mechanism uh in this class
and it actually consists of decomposing
the general uh problem into n
one bitter problem and and uh uh
so uh that's how it comes about and
and we are going to see that um any
mechanism in this class is naturally
decomposable
and now if you if you think about it
that
the what is the structure of a mechanism
in this class because you can
only assign the items to the highest
bidder so it means that when i look at
if you look at buyer i and if all the
other
values have been fixed for the other
buyers
then if you look at the maximum
value for every item then
you will not assign the item
to buyer i unless it's value it's
above that's uh that value
so uh that gives you the
uh the notion of something
called a a a a a
a a a a particular type of of
of of of one buyer auction as we
as we will see so um let's go to
notation
this is a standard notation the
evaluation of buyer i
and item j is x i j is drawn from a
distribution
over the positive numbers and the
payment is denoted by s
and the allocation is noted by q the q i
j
x is the allocation
of the j item to buyer i when the input
is is x and the mechanism is just
defined
by the allocation and the payment
and so now
as we said that's the decomposition
of the empire auction
into one buyer auctions have a special
nature
namely that they are we are interested
in one-dimensional auctions where there
is a threshold
beta and this beta when we apply it
to our case would represent the maximum
value
of the uh of the bits from the other
buyers
and the def so we'll say that
a mechanism so now we are considering
the one buyer k item
options and a mechanism is called the
beta exclusive
if no allocation can be made
if the bit is less than beta j
and now so
what do we want to do uh with our
how should we design our our our
mechanism
well we would want to design
the uh the best beta exclusive
mechanism that gives you the maximum
possible revenue
and now if you can do that then that's
the best you can do
and and so the the the to designers is a
simple
mechanism we would like to design some
simple beta exclusive mechanism
that are that
that that are a good approximation of
the best beta exclusive mechanism so
let's look at some examples
of the possible beta exclusive mechanism
the first one is selling separately
and we'll just pick a price vector
that is point wise greater than
the vector beta and we sell each item at
gamma at gamma g
and another example uh
is sort of an extended version of the
bundling
but this time with a surcharge so
basically
what we would like to do is for the
buyer to pick up those items
which their valuation is bigger
than the beta j and they should pick
those items
we'll give that bundle to them but they
have to pay
in addition to the beta j altogether
there is a search hw that they need to
pay so
you can see that but in both example one
example two
these are truthful mechanisms and they
are uh beta is
exclusive nobody wants to pick something
which
uh for which their true valuation is
less than that
are you in the sum you're summing
positive and negative numbers are you
mean so uh you were not
so
we are offering this price saying that
okay you can pick any subset
and but you have to pay those beta j and
the plus
an additional w so if you are you are
your
uh you are
your evaluation uh all together excess
valuation is less than w then you will
not you will not buy it
okay and now uh
let's look at both example one one and
two and let's try to combine them saying
that
let's define the beta bumbling as the
better
of these two possibilities one is to
sell it separately
for any pricing gamma greater or equal
to beta
or uh it is one uh this bundling
with surcharge for for any surcharge
value so you can see that we are
uh what we are doing is trying to extend
the uh bf at all
the the maximum of the selling
separately
and and the bundling uh in the for the
standard
uh one buyer uh clear item case
to the case uh when we have
this uh beta exclusive
uh mechanisms and
and not armed with that so
it seems that if the
the maximum of selling separately and
the bundling
uh is a it is a constant
factor approximation of the uh
of the the the one buyer k atom case
then the mechanism
we defined the beta bundling that we
defined uh
probably would also be a a good
approximation
of the best beta exclusive mechanism
so we work under that that that
conviction and so now with that we can
uh just put the pieces together and
define the very natural mechanism
uh in the following way that i'm given
a n by k bit matrix and where the items
are in the independent
and uh
the step one is for each bidder
for each buyer the seller would conduct
a one buyer k item auction where the bid
is just a bid
from the uh the id buyer and
the seller would use the beta bundling
for the distribution assuming that you
have already
seen the evaluations of all the errors
so conditional on that
you look at the distribution and you
design
the best beta bundling method
for that
and now clearly this is a deterministic
and truthful mechanism
and uh uh what we would like to show
is that uh this mechanism dbg
uh achieves a constant factor of the
optimal revenue
now in order to show uh to do that
uh let's assume that you have you have
any
mechanism m we want we will show
that each revenue is bounded by a
constant
times what can be achieved by the dbg
mechanism that we have mentioned
and now so the the idea is to compare
the revenue obtained from
m with that obtained
by dbg uh in a
reduced dimension namely that we would
like to
to actually compare each buyer
and we ideally we would like to show
that the the revenue contributed by
buyer i
is approximately the same in both cases
but of course uh in real algorithms
uh this this may not happen because uh
it is quite
quite possible that uh one can assign
all the items to one buyer and and
whether they are big or small and we get
an enormous
large uh revenue from it
uh so uh what we would like to do
is to uh uh to
to do some accounting trick namely that
will
do the accounting by redefining the
revenue contributed
by the id buyer in such a way that
the total revenue remains the same but
one can show
that in this adjusted revenue
the buyer i would have at most
the amount that the dgb
mechanism case and uh so
uh let's
do it in in formulas the
the revenue from dbg is the sum
contribution from all the buyers and
the expected value of that the beta i
bundling coming from the appropriate
distribution now the revenue coming from
the mechanism m we'll rewrite it so
that's we're going to take away
a portion uh which will
call it a dumping text and the
this portion is defined to be the
the sum of the the value
that is coming from selling the items
at below the the threshold price
so in other words we are trying to
discourage
the the the the the uh so if
if some uh if some buyer
contributes a big uh revenue
we'll try to kind of discourage the
uh loading up of uh that amount
by just just dumping a lot of the
small items to them and so we subtract
that off because that
that in our view is not a a
a good way of doing business and and so
let's rewrite it
in that fashion and now
what we can see is that one can call
the total revenue
is written as the sum of the adjusted
revenue
and plus a total tax coming from all the
buyers
and now the total tax actually turns out
to be small because
an item can only be sold once in terms
of the total fraction
so uh if you uh just add all these
together
if some buyer sold a lot
uh for some item then uh the other
buyers would
have to sell very little of uh i would
get very little from there
and so uh the the the the
it's easy to to see that the
uh the the the total
tax is bounded by the expected value
of the second maximum for all the items
so in other words
it's really uh bounded by the revenue
that can be obtained by a victory
auction so it's small according to our
considerations and now once we have
taken
care of that it remains and it suffices
to
to show that uh the adjusted revenue
it's uh it's it's it's bounded by a
constant
times the corresponding revenue coming
from the the beta
i bundling and and
and so in other words uh this means that
that if i
uh it's uh
um in terms of the adjusted
revenue you cannot do much much better
than just doing the
the beta bundling
and so uh let's just put them in
in symbols the revenue x is the optimal
revenue
by any beta exclusive mechanism and the
revenue
a is the optimal adjusted revenue
and we want to achieve the constant
the constant factor inequality by the
following two lemmas
one is that uh that that uh
the the if you compare the the the
optimal
uh adjusting revenue by any mechanism
and compare it with the optimum value by
any
uh beta exclusive mechanism uh it's at
most a factor off
and the second dilemma says that that
beta bentoni
is a pretty good beta exclusive
mechanism so if you
put these two things together then
it gives the desired inequality
that that would like to have and uh
the uh i would
mention that lemma one is really the
hardest part
of the uh technically the hardest part
of the proof
so uh let me just say a few words
about the proof of lemma one
and and uh in the in the uh
in essence the to prove this lemma
one need to to prove something of the
following nature
you have two distributions f and f prime
where f prime is obtained by relabeling
some of the points
in the support of f so it becomes a
different distribution
in this fashion and we need to prove
that
despite this re-labeling the optimal
revenue
for this distribution will still be a
constant factor
of the original one now
so in order to do this we need to
to do the following take the optimal
mechanism for f and we want to transform
it
into a mechanism n prime for the
new distribution such that the m prime
on f prime will have a constant factor
of the revenue of m and now uh
in general taking n prime what do you
mean by the labeling
uh so i look at the original support
and i would just relabel some of the
for example uh if originally it's 385
i would just label
label it relabel it by adding two
to both of them so that their their
value has been increased
so in other words it's sort of changing
the values
yeah changing the values not all
uniformly but but but some of them
and so it's a particular type of
of profile changing but it's a it's a
very specific one
are you preserving order
yes yes yes yeah it's but it's a
i mean it doesn't work in general it
just works for
the relabeling that that that we need in
order to prove this
uh but the the the uh the i think the
the the quality feature uh
that i'm going to mention i think it's a
general principle
that uh if you take if you say that well
since the
the labeling is not that
doesn't change that much uh if i just
use the original
mechanism how does it
would it work that will not work
and because the revenue would be
sensitive to relabeling
because the the uh uh you might
uh because we are interested in the
revenue
and just a small change in my opt funded
advantages to go to
an option where the price is much lower
so we want to prevent
people from defecting and instead
what we did was to modify the manual
original
by the following two things one is to
throw away the lower yield entries
the the entries where the price is small
and then for the remaining items that we
would
for the remaining entries will lower the
price of all those
by a constant factor so kind of give a
discount
and and so uh you can recognize this
property is a good
business practice for some company that
wants to
really keep its customer base and uh
now interestingly after this
modification
under the new manual for this new
distribution
it's a it's more stable so
essentially the customers usually
doesn't want to change
its option and if it changes it's going
to go for a higher price
and now the reason being that that that
that by lowering the price you are
increasing
the difference between the utility
of the buyer compared with the
the other options so unless you go for a
higher price
if if you go to a lower price
previously is not attractive then it
will still not be attractive
and and the difference is enhanced
sufficiently
so that if you do some relabeling of the
points you cannot overcome this
and and and and so that's the
and now let's come to the
uh about question two uh now
the question of whether the the bayesian
notion
of ic is a much uh
gives you gives you a much stronger
revenue
than the dominant strategy one it's an
interesting question that
i think that that in in myerson's work
it it shows that actually for the
one-dimensional case
debation is the same as the dominant
strategy
and uh uh uh uh the relation
between the patient and the dominant
strategy has been a
very consistent of interest
for researchers and and uh
even in the last few years i think there
are there are quite a number
of papers about the
uh equivalence of division
and the dominant strategy in the
one-dimensional case
uh with various uh uh refinement
it's not not just revenue but but but
other structures however for the
multi-item case
i think there has been
not that much known about it so
so we would like to answer it uh in the
case
when all the nk distributions are
independent
in our in our setting and and
uh now i'm just going to give you a
a a kind of a high level steps
of of this proof now
recall in the proof of theorem 1 we
said that any mechanism m
can be written down this revenue as the
sum
of a bunch of justice revenues and plus
a dumping
a dumping tax and and then we showed
that the dumping tax in that case
is bounded by the victory revenue and
therefore
uh now the
the fact that the adjusted revenue is uh
it's it's
it's bounded by uh some other things it
is another
uh ingredients but that's already uh
done
and so in the proof of theorem 2 we
would like to follow
the same sort of of of of outline we
want to show that any
of the bayesian ic mechanism
would satisfy the form that the revenue
can be written down as the sum of a
bunch of adjusted revenue
and uh plus a bic
dumping tax and the adjusted revenue is
exactly the same
adjusted revenue as in the in the
original case and so the fact that
that that that one one can make a
decomposition
of the uh the auction into n separate
disjoint uh one-dimensional
auctions give us so much structure
that it's possible to show that
that for even for the vision case it's
possible to manipulate the expression
so that you can write in this form but
admittedly
that the the in the proof of theorem 2
uh this step
this step right writing it down uh these
two parts
takes more imagination than the first
one i think that in the the proof of
theorem one
this part is completely trivial it's
just minus the term in the plus a term
and but in this case you'll have to
you have to do more in order to do it
and the interesting thing is that one
can show that
even though the the division i see the
dumping tags
is not bounded by the victory you can no
longer
write it down as the expected value of
this the second max
but uh fortunately you can bound it
by the value of the uh
of the selling selling item uh
separately using the best and and so uh
that's that's the the the essence of
what you need to do
and there are other results because
because after we have
uh gone through the theorem one uh
proof uh we have known so much about
the uh if we are if we only care about
constant factor approximation
then we have know so much that it's even
possible to write down
explicit expression uh for uh
for the for the auction in particular
if if all the items are are idf then
you can write down the revenue
explicitly up to a constant factor
and and uh furthermore it's possible to
to simplify the uh mechanism
for achieving this bound by uh uh
something called
a second price bundling so instead of
having a
bundling with surcharge that varies
depending on other inputs
you can just have chosen a uniform
parameter w and you say that i'm
performing
this bundling with the surcharge w for
all the ite for
for for all the buyers and and so it's a
it's a very simple description
uh that that can achieve that and so uh
in conclusion
uh we have seen that that it's possible
to to decompose it into
n one dimensional auctions and
the inside allow us to construct a
simple constant fraction approximation
and also other results such as uh
knowing the relation between business
and the revenue
and uh it's of course it's it's it'll be
very interesting
to have much improved solution because
the constant is fuel is still very large
and i certainly cannot believe that
that's the only solution
uh we can find and but i think the most
interesting
uh problem this is is really about
some bigger things i think that that the
uh the heart and the nissan showed that
for the
uh one buyer uh multi-item case the
auctions are are are additive
and uh but for the for the end buyer
case
and i i looked at it pretty hard but but
i just couldn't
find a way to make it work although i i
believe that
um that that that much it must be the
case
namely that if you have two auctions
that you want to do is it possible by
combining them into one auction
and and get a more than a constant
factor
of the uh that you can obtain by doing
it separately i think just
philosophically
it's a tremendously uh intriguing
uh question that and and and in fact
i believe that that if one can solve
questions of that kind you will get
you have to get a lot more insight into
the
multi-item auction problem so thank you
very much
um you showed that the exclusive
the beta exclusive mechanism achieves a
constant factor of the adjusted
but do you know of a distribution
mechanism where there's a gap between
the adjusted revenue
i do not know any i think that that that
as far as i can tell they could be that
you know that that
that that the the uh
beta exclusive is the is the best way
for doing that
yeah so it'd be very very interesting to
to to have a counter
a kind of a counter example
yes
of an example um the invasion is
strictly better i don't know i think
it's
quite interesting i think that in the
literature people have constructed
a multi-dimensional type of auction for
which that patient is different
however it's they are for a more general
type of auctions and
and for the natural options that we are
considering i i don't know any
any any such such example so um
i i don't know maybe once you do a
computer experiment i think it's just
simply that
somehow um the instances
the the the numbers get so large that
that it's hard to write it down and
check it manually
you